hey kelly what's up nothing
oh except oh my god jim last night ryan
and i
totally finally hooked up it was awesome
that's great
i'm really happy for it i know and it
was so funny because we were at this bar
with his friends and i was sitting next
to him the whole night
and he wasn't making a move so in my
head i was like ryan what's taking you
so long
and then he kissed me and i didn't know
what to say so i said
ryan what took you so long and he just
said it to him can you believe that
wow oh my god jim is that embarrassing
i'm embarrassed
no don't be no thank god because i was
nervous jim you will not believe
i was so nervous but now now i have a
boyfriend
all right i hooked up with her on
february 13th
oh my god she is so cute i want to die
don't you just love
kids angela i guess i wouldn't mind a
pair of small well-behaved boys
god i cannot wait to get pregnant and
have babies
kelly and i both agreed that we would
just have fun and
i'm learning that fun for kelly is
getting married and having babies
immediately with me
if i get to stay and ryan is laid off i
will kill myself
like romeo and juliet the claire danes
one
any other questions kelly kapoor
can we speak privately about our
relationship thank you everybody
so how are you awesome
i am dating a lot of guys good a lot
black guys mostly
kelly what i want you to tell me that
you care about me that is what i want
kelly i'm your boss now okay you can't
keep talking to me like i'm your
boyfriend
oh big strong man fancy new whatever i
don't think you ever cared about me i
never cared about you
six months ago karen filippelli sent me
an email asked me out
i said no because i was committed to our
relationship well i hope you're still
committed because i'm pregnant
and guess what buddy i am keeping it
okay
okay do you feel prepared to help me
raise a baby
i can't talk about this right now okay
after work we'll go out to dinner
we'll talk about it then okay
we have a date i don't understand what
the big deal is you don't
no you lied about being pregnant right
so you really don't understand why that
might make me kind of angry
no we're never getting back together why
not
it's whom when it's the object of the
sentence and who when is the subject
that sounds right well it sounds right
but is it how did ryan use it as an
object as an object ryan is me as an
object
i don't get the big fuss here i like the
site if i had created a website with
this many problems i'd kill myself
do you have a question kelly yeah i have
a lot of questions number one how dare
you
i can't do this can't do what it's not
fair to you
and it's really not fair to me wait what
are you saying i broke up with daryl so
i could be with you that was your choice
don't put that on me
i'm just going on a little trip oh can i
come it's not that kind of trip
i'm going to thailand with some friends
from high school well a high school
and if i don't do it now i'll never get
to go and i'll always resent you for you
don't want me to resent you do you
so you're dumping me speed thoughts
about this
let's have sex one more time and if you
have any extra cash that would be
amazing
okay i found these the other day while i
was journaling and
they reminded me of you oh those are
from our weekend to the timeshare yeah
the fractional ownership property
oh we took this one right before we got
in that huge fight god i don't even
remember what that fight was about we
were being really bratty about where we
would go out to dinner but
all i remember is how pretty you looked
taking those pictures of me
anyway if you want to order prints of
your own i can send you the link
i am in love with kali kapoor and i
don't know how i'm going to feel
tomorrow
or the next day or the day after that
but i do know that right here
right now all i can think about is
spending
the rest of my life with her
again that could change kelly
you're here hey ryan hey
whose baby is this oh are you like a
manny now no this little guy is mine
so i was dating this girl and one day
she went out to get a new charger for
her e-cigarette
never came back hold the story in the
book
say hi drake drake is your baby's name
yeah
that is an amazing name i'm obsessed
with drake his last album
it just touched me no kelly he's not
named after a hip-hop artist from 2011.
it's drake
like a mix of drew and blake
ravi ravi
drake has a bit of a rash and he's hot
i know i was wondering could you maybe
examine him for a second oh yeah you're
not feeling well little guy
okay sure um should we go inside
actually could you go inside i'm feeling
a
little
dehydrated i could really use a little
break have some water are you sure you
don't want to go in
ravi just do it that baby is burning up
isn't this like what you live for
just go go thank you ravi thank you so
much this is great for me after drake
thank you
i don't know ryan maybe drake didn't
look so good he'll be fine
i let him suck on a strawberry he's
allergic but i'll get over it fast i had
to talk to you
you gave your baby an allergic reaction
just to talk to me
i love you i love you too we're gonna be
together forever we're running off into
the sunset
i finally mastered commitment
[Music]
you